hier en début de soirée charles iii
accompagné par ses frères andrew edwards
et sa soeur anne vient rendre un nouvel
hommage à la reine elizabeth 15 minutes
de recueillement
autour du cercueil de leur mère
et sous le regard des écossais défilant
dans la cathédrale saint gilles puis le
nouveau roi a quitté les lieux sous les
applaudissements de la foule
[Applaudissements]
grosse semaine pour les successions un
nouveau roi au royaume uni ceci pour
nous il est évident que notre victoire
implique un peu plus de votes que celle
du prince charles
et bien non je veux dire je ne dis pas
que nous sommes plus légitime dans notre
position que lui laissons ça à d'autres
personnes
elle se réjouit de la mort d'elizabeth
ii en direct sur les réseaux sociaux
depuis cette vidéo la vie de jackie une
restauratrice écossaise opposé à la
monarchie n'est plus la même en plus des
critiques en ligne elle s'est mise à dos
les habitants de son quartier pour
preuve la devanture vandalisé de son
restaurant spécialisé dans les fish and
chips et l'escort policière nécessaire
vendredi soir face à une centaine de
riverains en colère et puis on va
refermer la page là dessus re cité j'ai
dit hier la formidable chronique de
gaspard proust que vous avez été vu dans
le journal du dimanche je pas la lire
entièrement mais il écrit ses îles ceci
alors là c'est drôle il prend un peu
d'esprit de distendre mais bon il faudra
s'y faire à 96 ans manie bentley il
appelle m'habille bentley a pété le
couteau dans l'accueil dans la quiche
depuis l'établissement est fermé
pire encore la fédération nationale du
fish and chips a résilié l'adhésion de
la restauratrice
si sa disparition nous touche tous ces
départs parce qu'elle était simple quand
elle venait en normandie c'était pour
acheter des chevaux comme tout le monde
elle aimé rouler en rolls décapotable
avec ses meilleurs amis des korgis pour
aller vite je vous parle d'un chien qui
évoque un teckel sur lesquels on aurait
greffé une tête de renard sous cortisone
et c'était à lire dans le journal du
dimanche qu'on me comprenne bien ce
débat que je n'aimais pas la reine
d'angleterre c'est juste que je m'en
foutais comment est ce que vous allez
aussi bien qu'à l'est républicain
c'est méchant pour moi pour
[Musique]
placer nicolas sarkozy écouter enfin ce
serait plus qu'auxerre
et vous moquez pas vous vous moquez pas
goûté que je suis moi je viens jouer
islam et qui en a d'autres qui prennent
la main avant moi je l'étais
football je sais pas faire parce que il
à l'épaule et la tête du coup j'ai en
même temps nicolas sarkozy c'est vrai je
sais pas pourquoi le comité d'éthique
vient de rendre un avis favorable à une
aide active à mourir sous conditions
strictes donc le rapport de
l'institution et publié quelques
semaines avant le lancement d'une
convention citoyenne dont la vocation
est de faire évoluer la loi claisse
leonetti qui interdit toujours le
recours au suicide assisté en exclu
voici ce que pense l'ancien président du
débat sur la fin de vie relancé par
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui de la
plantureuse les vieux sont papeete
il
s'agit de patients qui sont dans une
situation de fin de vie mais pas à court
terme mais plutôt à moyen terme c'est à
dire portant sur quelques semaines ou
quelques mois on peut citer certaines
affections neurologiques on peut citer
certains cancers qui sont en 3e 4e 5e
ligne de traitement avec des souffrances
difficile à la fois au plan physique et
psychologique
est ce que vous savez faire françois
hollande
oui et guti je me suis honoré de vous
rencontrer
parce que je vais vous dire la vérité
civile
je me sens proche de vous
tous les deux
merci merci du cinéma avec notre phrase
du jour et godard créa le mépris et
c'est à bout de souffle qu'il a rejoint
le firmament des derniers grands
créateurs des toiles allait saigner
brigitte bardot que jean luc godard
avait dirigé dans le mépris aux côtés de
michel piccoli le monstre sacré de la
nouvelle vague éternel révoltés de
septième art c'était aujourd'hui en
suisse à l'âge de 91 ans en ayant
recours au suicide assisté au cybardeaux
accepte de se dénuder elle n'entend pas
renoncer à sa coiffure en choucroute
godard lui propose alors un étrange
marché
parce que si je marche sur les mains ce
que chaque mètre que je marche sur les
masques ou accepter de baisser d'un
centimètre votre coiffure bardot accepte
le défi et godard s'exécute
vers la fin
que reste-t-il l'espérance l'espérance
oui d'une manière plaisante denis de
rougemont le disais
nous nous sommes sauvés quand espérances
mais cette espérance est vrai